Wow this really wasn't written last year
huh
[Music]
time deduce a bit more Big Finish before
I get into this first I got to do a
shout out to a patron because I've got
some really awesome patreon supporters
in this particular case I want to give a
shout out to a million pons grandfather
and I'm not even really kidding I have a
patron who has a granddaughter named
Amelia pond and she has a six-year-old
brother who wears bowties you know the
family that watches Doctor Who together
just is awesome together man I love my
patrons anyways so let's get to this
the fear monger so this is a audio
adventure for the Seventh Doctor and
Ayse Sophie Allred and aces you know the
iconic companion for the Seventh Doctor
so getting her back and having her
revived this part that's just a great
gig cuz she's always been great in this
part now as I've been trying to do with
the Big Finish I'm going to do my back
I'm pretty sure I can talk about this
without getting into spoilers I'm gonna
talk about some stuff and some specific
thing that goes on primarily in the
first episode so I'd like to think
that's not too spoilery talking about
some of the stuff that's in the first of
four episodes but even that I'll hold
off up because like I said I don't don't
expect people will have all heard this
the way that I can count on folks having
seen the episode so the fear monger is
set in near future Britain and it is
dealing with the rise of a far-right
political group calling themselves new
Britannia and they are you know coming
to power they're holding rallies they
have a very England first perspective
there they're against on the United
Nations they're against Europe they
really
cut England off from that there's a lot
of talk about you know immigrants and
and the others and them and there's
xenophobia and all this stuff worked
into it and there's something that is
feeding off of the fear that is being
generated by everything that's going on
between the rise of this party people
who are afraid of them people who are
fighting back against them to the point
that some people are in fact prepared to
try and assassinate the the leader of
this party and the doctor is here
because as I said there is something
that is just feeding off all this and
the whole situation threatens to just
boil over into a disaster
and that's about as far into the
starting premise as I think I can get
and if you were wondering what I meant
with that sort of opening intro bit this
feels like it could have been done last
year in response to brexit but it was
made in 2000 which is crazy I don't know
if anyone has revisited the well I don't
know what what folks thought about it
when it came out and I don't know what
people would think about listening to it
now I don't know if anyone's revisited
lately I'd actually be really interested
to hear in the comments from any fans
who remember their thoughts on this when
it when it originally came out or what
they think of it now but I tell you it
is pointed and it feels at this point
prophetic even and it it gives it I I
suspect I mean I I know obviously more
about the American political climate
than the British one so I don't know if
there was a kind of a rise of this sort
of thing at the time this was made but
you know for my understanding of
certainly what's going on now it feels
like it was made in response to what's
going on right now not 18 years ago the
that whole thing is crazy and it has it
has a it has a level of residence that
it may not have even had when it first
got released in terms of what I would
consider to be mine early spoilery on
the front end and again this this is
this is talked about in the very first
episode of the for that that make this
up and initially I was very skeptical
when we find out that there is some sort
of outside force that the doctoral first
who has the fear monger that is sort of
feeding into and feeding off of the
situation and initially when that got
introduced I felt disappointed because I
had hoped that the doctor was just gonna
be dealing with a mess of human beings
making and part of me got worried that
the whole message of the danger of you
know fearful political tactics and then
the countermoves that happen from that
and then the counters to the counters
and just how everything escalate spirals
out of control would lose some of its
impact when basically people who don't
want to have to think too hard about how
that applies to the real world can
basically go oh well there was an alien
doing it so I don't have to worry about
that except I actually think that the
show gets around that about as well as
you can if you're not gonna do a
straight and you are going to introduce
an outside force which is that well
first of all is brought up as I said
early so it's not like that was revealed
as a twist if we had gone say three
episodes of just dealing with humans
making the situation worse to be
revealed that in the fourth episode oh
there's this alien pulling strings that
would have been awful but even beyond
that it's the fact that while the fear
monger is a problem and it's making the
situation worse it's not controlling
people it's just they it's just taking
advantage of what's going on everything
that's done
every action every reaction it's just
people it's people being scared and
being stupid
and that is made pretty clear at a
number of points throughout the story
and that's good because without making
that clear like I said the the sort of
the cop out of oh I don't need to to
think about what this episode is
actually saying because you know it's
about it's about an alien messing with
people I don't have to worry about that
and it does a pretty good job of not
letting you get away with that excuse so
it really is very well done in terms of
the escalation and and laying out the
blame for all parties it would have been
really easy to create just a straw man
ultra conservative group or individual
to just pile on but there are very
pointed comments being made about them
about you know the the counterpoint
political view about entertainment
pundits
who are just that who are entertainers
but pass themselves off as being
political and who have an impact on the
political field even though they claim
to only be entertainers when pressed on
it and it has pointed things to say
about opposition groups it it's it
there's plenty of blame for the
situation to go around but not in a it's
a little bit of everybody's fault
because the fault is the is people not
thinking about the consequences of what
it is that they're doing and off and
usually just reacting out of fear so
that is the consistent problem and that
is a problem regardless of what your
political stance is that behavior is the
problem so I think it does it works
because it shows that that behavior is
not unique to any political stripe and I
think that was a good way to go about it
and there's and they take good advantage
of the audio medium
this and because they've got sort of
this recurring radio talk show that pops
up every now and then and that and it
allows for a number of things for some
interesting ways that characters end up
communicating with each other which is
kind of cool and also it becomes a good
way to have you know expositional news
flash dumps kind of things happen and
all that works pretty seamlessly the
acting is really good in this and you
know Sylvester McCoy here I did like him
as the Seventh Doctor but Sophia Allred
is ace makes him better they're dynamic
they're chemistry what they bring out of
each other as performances and as
characters makes both of them better so
having them both here is really awesome
and Sophia Rai
I only saw I think I've only seen to
date three stories that have ace in them
and she's always been good and I've
always liked her but I feel like I get a
much better sense of her as a character
and a sense of what she is capable of
and her potential and what the doctor
sees in her what she brings out of him
in this audio that I think I really got
how to any of the other episodes and
again all the episodes I've seen her in
of the show proper were good and she was
good in them but this just feels like
it's a an even better showcase for her
than any of the episodes that I saw the
supporting cast is all good the the wood
the woman running for office who's sort
of the head of this conservative group
she's really good because she she gets
humanized but not in in a way that feels
manipulative just in a very
matter-of-fact way just by having her
have interactions and having her express
emotions that feel very human so that
even if you vehemently disagree with her
politics she doesn't come across as you
know this this sort of moustached or
like and I shall now close the
children's orphanage those freeloading
welfare queens kind of way which would
have been the you know
again the cop-out way to do it I feel
like this story is tackling stuff that
would have been really easy to take an
easy route on to take a safe route to
take a punching down approach but it's
not it's it's all handled pretty
thoughtfully and pretty even-handedly
and pretty at this point certainly with
what's happened since it was really
frightening ly believably so I think
that's really all I can talk about
without getting to spoilers I'm I'm not
sure any of the spoilers that I could
talk about our worth getting into I'm
not sure I have anything to say that's
really beyond too much of what I've said
here it's a great cast it's a good story
it's phenomenally executed and it is
shockingly relevant and every now and
then you just come across a piece of
media you know written and made years
ago and you read it and it's about you
know some issue and you read it or you
hear it or you see it and it just
immediately sinks in like oh my god this
feels like this could have been written
right now because this issue is still
going on there was a there was a play I
did a staged reading for about I guess
would have been about three years ago
now play called trouble in mind written
by a woman named Alice Childress and
it's looking at relationships and
understandings and misunderstandings and
misperceptions and prejudices between
people that all felt shockingly relevant
and I knew I knew it was I knew when the
thing was set but it felt like something
written in the last 10 years that was
just set in the 50s and
then as we were going through the
rehearsal process and the the director
told me no this was actually written in
1955 but when it was set and hearing
that just blew my mind cause like craps
things haven't gotten better and I had
that same feeling hearing this audio and
going god it's 18 years later and this
feels possibly even more relevant now
than it that it would have at the time
and I think that makes it more powerful
and makes it all the more worth
listening to and it's a good it's a good
Doctor Who story besides it's it's the
least fantastical of the ones that I've
listened to so far it you know it's set
on earth it's set in the future
technically but it's in the pretty near
future so it's all a lot more grounded
it's all a lot more believable there's a
lot less just fantastical elements in it
but it just works especially for the
story that is telling him and the points
that it's making I thought this was a
terrific piece of work and well the ton
of great touches - I mean especially if
you know Doctor Who history there's
there's some fun ways in which the
doctors history with unit sort of plays
into the story a little bit and just a
lot of awesome stuff to watch out for
and he's great Sophie all Reds amazing
and this I loved this those are my
thoughts on the fear monger I have no
idea if this is a particularly well
regarded audio or not but it should be
at least as far as I'm concerned so have
you heard it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all that stuff you
can do things like support me on patreon
follow me on Twitter listen my podcast
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]